welcome to this video playing super
cheese from this australia or new
zealand australia ah alright bernie is
about 2200 rated and we couldn't Raghu's
in Queens gambit with the holy Bishop
before it's quite an interesting line to
UM to get them bit a bit more unbalanced
play compared to lots of other lines in
the Queens gambit check
instead of taking he also had c5 yeah
this is very similar to them um to the
NIMS oh no so with Quincy to where
there's also this pawn sack but i'm i'm
a hoe tempo up in this position because
i haven't played a three if i'm not
mistaken and i don't really believe in
this porn set go with an extra move so
um he's going nite a 6 i'd like to
control before and make sure that let's
say after Queen c3 that's Bishop f5 Roxy
aid I don't lose some any more time yes
this is this is possible of course yeah
I'm 95 so the principal move and I'm
going to play it if he retreats now to
f5 or somewhere I can play III and then
continue to develop if he goes to h5
however that's the possibility of 97
what okay so he's ignoring it
interesting ok Knight g4 Queen D forum
and then you are saying night before as
the threat I don't really believe that
this is working but what about III just
a simple solution yeah do that this is
simpler and I threaten Bishop a6 to
simplify it's still hanging and then he
doesn't really have a move here Pusha
basics and castles if I manage that it's
just it just over
or at least an there's no serious
compensation then um should I take on a
six I mean this is not a great piece but
it's um it's speeding up my plane yeah
yeah it's a matter of two speed iums I
shouldn't be reluctant to take them okay
I could take d5 and I will it's it's a
central pawn 97 to exchange play as
simple as possible
so my two additional points d 493 I mean
it's just one one extra bowknot a7s this
double bond is not exactly great so how
to continue is a four Emmys or should I
go rook rook see one looks the age
something like that
okay let's let's start with making some
roof for the king
clean f6
lighten this queen is nicely placed on
f5 it takes the pawn it covers f2 so I
can now use my rope here
c5 ssstill Queen f6 one doesn't really
help
when i'm asked you must have how is he
covering a day three Pawn
I think it's just gone
I'm always protecting be one Luke a one
and the queen is some nicely covering
ok this I didn't see of course
mmm there's so much some way to
okay I need to take you to take anyway
check so Quinn here Queen 83 it's got
even Queen each one
can I didn't see a rogue f2 of course
very very disappointing from from an
autopilot win 2 to better know what it
was very very easily winning it just
shouldn't overlook rook f2 and would it
still somewhat better for white but
unbelievable
yeah look be true
I can frost a draw with Roxy a probe
Jana to do that Jan crap game check look
F to check check check check check he's
not frustrated wrong button maybe his
plane g600 get him draw and now we
pressed it no I would have done so as
well rook f2 what a silly tactic i
didn't see that at all of course yeah
check probably i can i can play yeah
this is actually good to the computer
recommendation this is good Gary check
this is still um very good for white I
get to get the King here and I mean this
is not two pawns this is a double porn
yeah the term should still be very good
for white yeah but I was supposed to be
to be too shocked probably about all
this so now you see a check here yeah
theoretically speaking maybe I can and
we as always got this counter play you
know this is just a draw I just still
need to avoid Rugare to I'll play this
this other line with Queen at one so on
it's some term rather only draw him
alright thanks for watching